[Music]
a universal newsreel of 1966
president lyndon johnson gives his third
state of the union address
the
cup of peril
is full in vietnam
that conflict is not an isolated episode
but another great event
and the policy that we have followed
with strong consistency since world war
ii
history is on the side of freedom
and is on the side of society's shape
from the genius of each people
history does not favor a single system
or belief
unless force is used to make it so
and that's why it's been necessary for
us to defend this basic principle of our
policy to defend it in berlin and in
korea and in cuba
and tonight in vietnam
[Applause]
[Music]
we will stay
because in asia and around the world
are countries whose independence rests
in large measure
on confidence
in america's word
and in america's protection
the yield of force in vietnam would
weaken that confidence
would undermine the independence of many
lands
and would whip the appetite
of aggression
we would have to fight in one land and
then we'd have to fight in another
or abandon much of asia to the
domination of communism
[Applause]
[Music]
and we do not intend
to abandon asia to conquest
[Music]
[Applause]
the president asks for a record budget
112 billion 800 million dollars he hopes
to carry out most of his great society
plans
because of vietnam we cannot do all that
we should
are all that we would like to do
we will
ruthlessly attack waste and inefficiency
we will
make sure that every dollar is spent
with the thrift
and with the common sense
which recognizes how hard the taxpayer
worked in order to earn it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]